- Good morning, everyone.
I'm Rohini Pande, I'm a
Professor of Economics
at Yale and Director of
the Economic Growth Center.
It's my great pleasure to welcome all
of you to this concluding event
of a three day celebration
of the 65th anniversary
of the Master's in International
Development Program.
And it's also part of
the 60th year celebration
on the Economic Growth Center.
So, when I started the
as the Director of the
Growth Center last year,
I spent some time just
going over the archives
of Economic Growth Center and IDE Program.
And what was striking to me was just what
a fertile period the 1960s was.
I think more generally
for development economics
but especially at the Growth Center.
You know, the 1960s marked the end
of colonialism in most parts of the world.
And when a lot of open
questions about, you know,
both how should low income
countries set their course
for the future, but also importantly
what were the roles and responsibilities
of academics and policymakers
in richer countries?
And these discussions were really mirrored
in the Economic Growth
Center and the researchers
who came through in the
student discussions.
One of the first markers or
one of the first activities
of the Economic Growth Center
was the country studies program
with side faculty members
like Alejandro Carlos Diaz
to Latin America.
And they found strong
networks in those countries
which continued after they came back.
And I think as we look at the
Growth Center past, present,
and future I think it's these links
with researchers across the globe.
That is one of the things that at least
I believe EGC should be very proud of.
Latin America was I think,
central to this in the 1960s,
there was a lot of engagement
between what was happening
in Latin America with discussions
with economic development
more broadly and with the Growth Center.
And so, we're delighted
to welcome Edmar Bacha,
and Ana Cecilia Fieler
who will lead a discussion
on the Brazilian economy.
So, let me start by
introducing both our panelists.
So, Ana Cecilia Fieler is a
visiting Assistant Professor
at Economic Growth Center and
Yales Economics Department.
She earned her PhD from
New York University,
and has worked at Princeton University,
and the University of Pennsylvania.
In her research she combines
data and models to study
the effect of international trade
on labor markets and technology adoption
in developing countries
We are particularly
delighted to welcome her
because she will be
joining the IDE program,
and teaching macro economics in the fall.
Professor Edmar Bacha graduated
from the Yale IDE Program in 1965.
And he was the first student from
his original training program in Brazil
to be accepted in a doctoral program
after single year
post-graduate coursework.
He continued on to Yale economics,
and received his PhD in 1968.
He's taught in several universities
both in the United States and Brazil.
He's held positions as an economist
in policy making organizations
like the United Nations
and the World Bank.
And he's particularly
well known for being part
of a group of economists who came up
with a plan based on virtual currency
that succeeded in slowing down
Brazil's rampant inflation
in the 1990s.
So, we're delighted that Professor Bacha
has joined us today and I
will hand it over to him now.
He will give a presentation
for around 20 to 25 minutes,
followed by a discussion
of first the presentation,
and then a Q&A with a Professor
Bacha by Cecilia Fieler.
And then after that, I open for Q&A.
We delighted by the
audience that's joined us.
We also realize that we
may not be able to get
to all Q&A's, but Professor
Bacha has kindly agreed
that if as you write your questions
you could also provide your email address.
Then he would be very happy to respond
to them by email later.
So, Professor Bacha, thank you again
for joining us and over to you.
- Pleasure.
Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be back
to Hillhouse Avenue after
so many years even if it is only virtual,
I'm only sorry that after this
we can not go out together
either to Pepe's or Sally's
for a beer and the pizza
but anyways, maybe next we will do that.
My presentation today, you
know, it's based on my paper
that we published in five years ago.
It's a joint paper
with my dear late friend Regis Bonelli.
And it was used for
call as I read it here,
"Accounting for the rise
and fall of Brazil's growth
after world war two."
But given that the Brazil has
not improved actually has,
gotten worse, you know,
since we finished the paper
I decided to change the title
to something more dramatic
which is "What's gone wrong
with Brazil's economy."
And my presentation
it's story in four acts,
I first are going to show
you, you know, one slide
how far behind the US,
Brazil has stayed over time.
So, giving you a historical perspective.
Then I focus more in detail
in the growth, collapse
of Brazil after 1980.
Formulate the hypothesis that we had
in this paper that I
mentioned for this collapse,
and provide some arguments
for this hypothesis,
and then shift over to Ana Cecilia to see
what else she has to add.
We start with this comparison with the US.
In this slide, you know, we
see the ratio of Brazil's
to US per capita income,
all the way back from 1822, 2020.
I divided this periods here
into six politically
important periods for Brazil.
We, after we became
independent of Portugal in 1822
we had the constitutional
monarchy which lasted
for most of the 19th century.
Then we decide to imitate
the United States,
and became presidentialist
with the first republic.
We had the famous dictator
Getulio Vargas coming in
for 15 years, and then
after he was dismissed,
after the end of the second world war
we have this second Republic.
The militaries took over again in 1964
from the a follower of Vargas
that was president at the time.
They stayed on for 25 years.
And since 1985, you know, we have we, I
we having a democracy,
even though we have all
these difficulties that we're having now
with the current president.
But anyways, in terms of this
per capita income comparisons
to the US you can see that, you know,
as Brazil became independent,
we the per capita income Brazil
was something like 60% of
the U S.
Then by the end of the 19th century
this had gone down to 30%.
It continued to decline
up until the 1920s,
Brazil start growing fast, you know.
United States entered the reset
the depression in 1930,
but afterwards recovered very
nicely during the world war.
So, that the beginning of the period
that I'm going to consider
in the following, you know,
1945 Brazil had the per capita income
which was only 20% of the US.
And then we started
catching period, you know,
very hopeful that, so that by 1980,
Brazil's per capita income
had gone up, you know,
a little bit above 40% of
the US but then, you know,
and this is all that we're
going to talk about, you know,
things have been going
downwards mostly all the time.
And today we are only
at something like 23%
the per capita income of the US.
Looking more specifically
at the post-war period
here in this second slide,
I show you the Brazil's GDP growth rate
from 1950 to 1920.
In blue, the annual GDP growth rate,
in orange, a 10 year moving average.
As you can see from the 10
year moving average, you know,
all the way for actually
just from 1940, right?
Brazil was growing very
nicely, you know, over 7%.
This was up until close to the 1980.
There was a deceleration
around 75, but things along
if you look at the orange line, sorry,
there was a very deep
contraction of the economy.
It continues to contract
up until the 1990.
That was the last decade.
And then, you know, up
and down a little bit
with the commodity cycles.
And now, you know,
Brazil has really after
1940 tremendous bad periods
of which I'm not going
to talk much about, you know.
And over the last 10 years actually
the Brazil GDP growth rate has been zero.
So, but my point that
point to discuss, you know,
what happened, you know, in
Brazil was growing so nicely,
up until 1980 after the second
world war catching up to
the US, and then apparently
all of a sudden, you know,
if as a function of
the debt crisis of the early eighties,
Brazil fell, and have never
more recovered, you know,
we grew seven and a half
and then start growing
at two and a half.
You know, this is the focus
of the analysis that follows.
And then in order to
analyze this, you know,
I use it very simple GDP growth
scheme, you know, I'd say.
One factor of production growth scheme.
It's GDP depends on the capital stock
in order to have capital stock to grow,
we need savings.
And that's where the process here starts.
You know, we start from savings,
and depending on what the
capital goods prices are
these savings motivate an increase
in this thought of capital
goods and given this increase
in this stock of capital goods,
depending on the productivity of capital
you'll get GDP growth.
You know, this is basically
what I'm going to be showing
to you, you know,.
So there are three
fundamental variables here
to explain GDP growth.
One is savings.
The other is the price
of a new capital goods
that these savings are buying,
and then the productivity
of this capital goods in
order to generate GDP growth.
So, there are three factors here
that explain the evolution of GDP growth.
We start with savings.
You know, this is evolution
of the saving rates by periods
from 1947 to 2020,
divided in eight periods
from 1947 to 2010 again.
And that's, you can see here,
no I drove quick to focus
on total savings, the domestic savings
is the orange line
external savings are the
is the blue line, but I focus
on the dark line here
for the total savings.
You see that, you know, during
this period up until 1980
was a period of increasing saving.
And from 1980s, onward is the
period of decreasing savings.
So, you can see in those
savings was a fact, you know,
in this slowing down of growth.
But if you take an average,
you know, 47 to 80,
compared to 80-2020, the
difference, you know,
in terms of average is we looking at
these long historical periods,
the difference in average
is not very much, it's about
it's only 7%, you know.
You couldn't explain the
drop of GDP growth from 7 1/2
to 2 1/2 on the basis of savings alone.
You know, it contributed,
but it contributed.
I go, I was going to argue,
you know, only marginally,
more important for what
happened to GDP growth
was the these factor which
is the capital goods prices.
You know, the ratio of
investment prices to the prices
of GDP, which is here.
We have the showing this
capital good prices,
and we have an index with the
price in 2000 equal to one.
And as you can see, you know,
I had to adjust the
Regis and I had to adjust
to this period that have adjusted prices.
Here is a period of hyperinflation.
The National Council
went crazy too, you know.
So, we just forgot
about the original price
for the national accounts
and make an adjustment here.
But anyways, it shows
quite clearly, you know,
which is a very unique
phenomenon in Brazil.
You know, if you compared
you don't find this
in other countries, you know.
A very substantial increase
in the price of capital goods
throughout dispute from the
1950s, up until the eighties.
And this essentially, you
know, show that, you know,
if you compare now the
average price of capital goods
in the period of 1980
to 2019, this is 30%,
30% higher than it was in
the period previous to 1980.
So, that was a very substantial
part of the explanation
that even those savings
did not decline much,
the purchasing power of
savings over capital goods.
That became very substantially,
not because you had less savings
but because the prices of capital goods
that the savings were buying
increased so substantially.
The second phenomenon that
explained the growth collapse
is capital productivity
shown in this slide
from 1950 to 2020.
This is GDP divided by
the stock of capital.
And again, you can see,
you know, that throughout
this period up until 1980,
there was a continuous decline
in the capital productivity in Brazil.
And the average that we have
in the period,
after 1980, compared to
the period previous to 1980
is the decline of 25%, you know.
So, you see, you know, capital
productivity declined 25%,
the price of capital goods increase 30%,
and savings declined by 7%.
And all this to get
put together, you know,
is what explain why GDP growth declined
from 7 1/2 to 2 1/2
When we compare pre to post 1980.
That's the fundamental
explanation that we elaborate
in the paper that I previously mentioned.
So, my conclusion here, tentative
because I'm going to try to
substantiate in the following
is that the collapse in
GDP growth since 1980
had more to do with lower
capital productivity,
and higher capital goods
prices than to reduce savings.
Hypothesis is that these two
phenomenon are interconnected.
They are a consequence
of Brazil maintaining
its economy closed to international trade.
Brazil deepened an inefficient
import substitution process.
Instead of promoting
exports as the countries
that overcame the so-called
middle-income trap did
as I will show in the following.
The consequences of this process
of inefficient import
substitution, this deepening of
this inefficient import
substitution process,
the consequences were hacked
up higher capital good prices,
and low capital productivity
i.e lower GDP growth.
And I now going to make some comparisons
to substantiate this hypothesis.
The first compares that I make
is with Brazil compared
to South Korea here
who have the ratio of Brazil's
to South Korea's per capita
GDP from 1950 to 2020.
As you can see up until 74, Brazil had
a higher per capita
income than South Korea
but South Korea start
catching up, you know,
from the early sixties.
And then, you know, not only catch up
but over past Brazil and today, you know,
Brazil GDP per capita is
only 1/3 that of Korea.
Why this happened, you know,
there are many explanations
in the literature.
The one that I like best is this one.
Is this graph show, the
trade ratios meaning
the sum of exports plus
imports over GDP of Brazil,
and South Korea from 1953 to 2019.
Brazil is this solid line,
South Korea is the dotted line.
As you can see, you know,
up until the early sixties,
both countries were following
the same import substitution process,
industrialization flow,
import substitution.
But from the early sixties,
which is exactly the point
from which South Korea is
start taking off as I showed in
the previous slide.
South Korea is starting having a process
of export promotion, increasing
the participation of trade in GDP.
So, that starting from something like 7%
in the early sixties, South
Korea is our trade ratio today,
is something like 110%, while
Brazil which had, you know,
5% braid ratio in the early sixties
only grew very very slowly and today
as a trade ratio exports plus
imports over GDP of only 24%.
Brazil remained closed
while South Korea opened up.
It's not only South Korea,
actually the 12 countries
that overcame the middle-income
trap after world war,
all of them did so by integrating
into the world economy
as the trade to GDP the
last column in this table,
clearly show.
Let's focus on the median
the trade to GDP median ratio
the trade to GDP ratio median.
The median of that for
this country is 77%,
compared to Brazil, 24.
These countries are three
times more open than Brazil is.
And look at that, you know,
that now at the first column
GDP per capita in thousand dollars.
This country has have a per capita income
of $43,000 compared to Brazil,
15,000 or three times higher.
Again, you know, this
a very nice coincidence
that I like it.
It's interesting.
This country is, you know, why?
The the way they integrate
it to the world economy
were different, you know,
some export that industry,
South Korea, Hong Kong,
Israel, Singapore, Taiwan.
Some exported services, Spain,
Greece, Ireland, Portugal,
and some export and
natural resources, Norway,
Australia, New Zealand.
The way they did it depends
their comparative advantage
as you know, but they, that
one fundamental characteristics
of all of this country is
that in order to be now rich,
compared to the fact that
they were middle-class,
previous to the world war
second world war, the reason is
that they participate very substantially
in the world economy as
shown by their straighten
to GDP ratios in contrast to Brazil,
and why is so important?
And now I'm going to conclude, you know,
to participate in the world
economy in order to grow
it is because growth is
essentially productivity gains.
And after you reach middle class,
after you have all your
population in urban sectors,
you know, the only way to
have productivity gains
is to participate in international trade.
Why is that?
Because international trade
allows you that option,
state of the art technology,
modern capital goods,
productive capital goods,
cheap capital goods.
Data allows you the generation
of economies of scale
because you're not limited
to the domestic market.
You'll have all the world
at your disposition,
and allows you to specialization in lines
of production in which a country has
a comparative advantage.
Finally, also equally important,
it gives you market competition, you know,
survival of the fittest,
which is a fundamental test
for increasing productivity
and allowing GDP growth,
something that Brazil
unfortunately did not do.
And this is why basically I
would like to submit to you
we are now in this situation
that we cannot find way out,
a way out in order to recover
a more decent growth rate
as we have in the past,
Muito obrigado
- Muito obrigado sio.
So, I would like to start
by thanking Professor Bacha
for the wonderful presentation,
and for accepting the
invitation from the IDE,
and also remind the audience
that the chat is close to them.
So please post your questions on the Q&A.
What I'll do next is--
- Ana Cecilia, should I
stop sharing or you're going
to use my--
- I'm not going to use your screen.
So, here says some of
the questions are about
the your presentation.
You may wanna bring them back.
What I'm going to do is just
briefly summarize my research,
and the that will naturally
bring in some questions
to Professor Bacha.
As he highlighted in his presentation,
international trade was the
linchpin of economic policy
in virtually all the countries
that cruise sustainably
after world war 2.
In my research they'll
send to firm level data,
precisely to understand
the mechanisms through
which international trade
affects economic development
especially in developing countries.
So, when a firm from a
developing country engages
in international trade
where they throw imports
of intermediate imports or exports
with developed countries trade of firm.
It typically upgrades the
quality of its products,
technologies and management practices.
Firms in developed countries
are generally more advanced,
and there are several
reasons why they may want
their trading partners to also
upgrade that their quality.
For example, the automated
production process,
typically requires precise
specification for ports,
and higher quality materials.
Just in time inventory management,
and integrated computer systems
require trading partners
to be organized and flexible
with their deliveries,
billings, and even product
specifications after all,
adapting to shocks is one
of the main advantages
of just-in-time.
This upgrading of quality among
the importers and exporters
is well documented in the literature.
What's less well known is
that for the same reasons
the importers and
exporters as they upgrade,
they also required their
trading partners domestically
to upgrade.
And these importers and exporters tend
to be very large firms.
And so, even a relatively small amount
of international trade
may have a large effect
on the domestic market.
The symbol of effect
this particularly felt
in the labor market because
more advanced technologies be
them programmable machineries,
module management practices
they all compliment skilled workers.
meaning countries in
Africa and the Middle East
and lots of America,
including Brazil itself
that liberalized to international trade
in the 1980s and nineties saw the wages
of their college graduates
increase by 10 to 20% relative
to their less skilled workers.
So, a very dramatic increase in inequality
in just a few years.
The demand for skills in manufacturing
also went up dramatically in South Korea,
and other Southeast Asian countries.
But what these countries
did differently was
that they invested very
heavily in education.
The manufacturing sector grew,
adopted better practices,
invested and improved their productivity.
Arguably also had large positive effects
on the rest of economy.
While Brazil and other Latin
American economies firms
also upgraded and became
more skill intensive
but they became more skill intensive
by shedding their unskilled workers
mostly to the informal sector.
Manufacturing, the manufacturing sector
as Professor Bacha has
himself documented decrease
in Brazil from 25% of GDP to 15%.
And it didn't have the
same positive effects
in the rest of the economy.
Now, the second difference
between East Asia,
and Latin America is that East
Asia promoted its exports,
and engaged in international
production chains
while Brazil and other
Latin American countries
similarly, they lower their trade tariffs
but their infrastructure
remained a puppet,
their ports corrupted.
And this makes the cost in
timing of the flow of goods
into the country high and unpredictable.
Which makes it very
difficult for Brazilian firms
to engage in international
production chains
when you need good goods to
come in and out of the country
in a predictable and less costly
way especially when firms,
and the rest of the world they were trying
to maintain being inventories.
So, putting this research backgrounds,
together with Professor Bacha's work leads
to a few questions.
So, first is that I just suggested that,
and again Professor Bacha has
insisted in his previous work
that in order to fully take advantage
of international trade
and growth prospects
the country needs to invest in
infrastructure and education.
Professor Bacha shows
however in previous work
that the tax burden in
Brazil was high for a country
of its income level.
In most of this tax revenues was absorbed
into the pension and payroll system.
So, professor Bacha, can
you tell us a little bit
about structural reforms and in particular
the recent reforms of the
pension system, how deep was it,
is your administrative
reform politically viable
so that resources can be freed up
for infrastructure and the education?
- Ana Celia, thank you for
the very good compliment.
I subtly stimulated to
read more of your research,
and integrate these your results into
my own work.
And there are comments,
you know, about that
other factors besides
opening to trade, you know,
in order to explain, I brought
some additional slide just
in case, you know, which essentially
I have directed to this process,
if I can move here to, yes.
You know, that's opening
up to international trade
is a necessary condition but
it's not sufficient, you know.
And there's, you know,
if you can see, you know
if you're a big in a
country like Mexico is same
as Brazil, you know,
Mexico even after opened up
to international trade very nicely.
You know, it used to
have a 20% trade ratios
is now has 17% while Brazil,
you know, used to have 10,
it's now at that 24.
But nonetheless, you know,
the growth experiences
of both Mexico and Brazil
are very similar though.
Mexico also was growing
fast happened to median,
and then sunk, you know.
And never saw a growth
resume in anymore, you know,
not even with even after helping along.
And this means that
other factors intervene,
as far as you know, when
you are both big and Nico
and one of them, as you
mentioned, this application
or education quality in Brazil,
according to the PISA 2015,
is very bad, you know, in science
sorry for being using Portuguese.
But you know, that's the way it is.
In sciences, in reading in mathematics,
Brazil is way down, you know,
in terms of the rating
that Brazilian students gap
in this international competition.
And it's not so much,
you know, the question
of education is spending
in the horizontal hacks.
You have location in spending per people.
- I'm sorry, we can't
see your news slides.
I don't think your--
- I'm sorry, you cannot see what?
- Your slides we don't see it.
- They're not showing?
Not any of them?
- I don't see them.
Maybe someone else in
the panel can intervene
as they see it.
- [ Woman] No, we can't see it.
- Sorry.
- [Woman] No, we can't see it.
- Oh anyway, I'm sorry.
- You can describe.
- They can kind of describe
here, but anyway, this is the
there is a graph that showed
education spending per pupil
compared to the piece
of results, you know.
And Brazil, we haven't though it's spends,
you know.
Normally for its income
level but the quality of
its educational it does
not show in the results.
You know, Chile spends
as much as Brazil or away
and they have a much better
results in PISA than Brazil has.
And so, the education
quality is not only spending
is very important.
The other factor is the very
low quality of infrastructure,
you know.
This, that this picture
that you're not seeing,
and also the low quality of infrastructure
in the BRIC countries.
Let me see if I can do
something here, sorry.
Is that better now?
- No, maybe if you'll
send an email to Scott
with the presentation attached
to sO he can share it.
- [Man] Professor Bacha, are these
on your additional slides?
- Yeah, what about this now?
- [Man] Now, I think you're
sharing the wrong screen.
- Well, okay anyways.
So, I showed that the
infrastructure in all the Brazil
is the worst of the BRIC's.
And then the next one
is just to show Brazil
has very taxed, very high tax rates.
We taxed Brazilians more
than the Japanese tax,
the Japanese.
We tax Brazil is more than
the Americans tax the US tax
to the Americans.
So, even though we have a
tax rate, which is very high
which is concentrated
in indirect tax is not
in direct taxes.
All of these go into pension spending.
Brazil is the country that relative
to this dependency ratio.
The ratio of old to young people
is the country that
spends more in the world.
In terms of pension, you
know, we spend nothing
they spend like 50% of GDP on pensions.
And we also spent very
substantially with public servants.
30% of GDP, only South
Africa spends more than us.
And when you add that
up, you know, dispensers
of the government with pensions
and we've civil servants,
you know, they get to near
to 80% of the total budget.
So, there is very little left
in terms of something tried to fisher here
in terms of alternatives for
the government to spend in,
you know, even improving
the quality of education.
Also the quantity of education,
in health, in education,
and in, and the infrastructure.
So basically, you know
besides having an efficient private sector
because it's not integrated
into the world economy
we have a bloated public sector.
So we besides, you know, opening up,
we also need a very
substantial reform, you know.
Administrative reform and
the reform in our tax system
in order to be able, you know,
to provide education and infrastructure
in order to compliment what
the gains that we would observe
in case the Brazil finally
decides to open up.
- [Woman] Okay, just a
short point in education.
And that's a little bit
outside of your research
but you'll correctly mentioned
that it's not so much
the amount of spending.
I think that US has the same
issue, but it's the quality.
Have you seen any or are
there any types of policy
to try to improve the quality that
you find particularly persuasive
in terms of improving education?
- Well, you know, there are lots
of experiments in Brazil,
you know, especially
when the state of a poor
state of Ceara in particular
the state of the interior of
Ceara which is called Sobral,
you know, which has
a behavior in terms of
the quality of education
that's substantially higher
than any other else in Brazil,
you know?
And they didn't do no magic, you know.
They just, there had a stimulus ban.
The state gave back some taxes
to the cities and towns
that improved their education
performance, you know,
that, you know, money helps.
They also look very careful
in terms of the, you know,
the size of classes, the
quality of the teachers,
and the special, you know,
the quality of the directors
of the primary schools.
So, you know, it can be done.
And the problem really is,
you know, not so much then,
you know, in terms of
spending though, we, you know
we do need some of that, you know.
But this whole would be
possible to emulate and to use
these experiences that you have, you know,
experiences to send to,
which is another poor state
also had a tremendous improvement
in the educational system,
you know, so it can be done.
You know, I think is
fundamentally a question
of political will.
- That's very difficult.
Let me go back to the question
of openness and differences
in policy between the Latin America, Asia.
So, you were one of the
architects of the health plan
as Rohini mentioned,
which successfully ended
the Brazilian struggle
with inflation, for which my
generation is very grateful.
And the plan in 1994 team shortly
after the 1991 trade liberalization.
It involves the tighter
monetary policy and resulted
in real exchange rate appreciation.
This made it difficult for
presiding firms to compete
with imports and exports
and to export their outputs.
Now, if Brazil were to open up
more for international trade
to be, is it viable for
it to follow the example
of the seizure and
maintain its exchange rate
to devalued without
inflation picking up again?
What's your take on that?
- You know, (mumbles)
unfortunate coincidence
of experiments, you know, because we
there was an opening up in 1990.
We chose in relative well, you know,
with some sectoral and
the regional difficulties
but overall it was improving.
But then, you know, we
had the system it was
a fixed exchange rate system
in the period, you know.
First it was a parity with the dollar.
And then when we made the rail plan.
The rail plan was very successful,
but it had to rely, you know
in order to keep inflation bow
on an exchange rate anchor.
So, and that exchange rate
anchor low-pro provide produced
an overvaluation of the currency.
So, that on top of the decline in tariffs
we also have an
overvaluation of the currency
which below submitted
are domestic producers
two very strong pressures.
And they eventually,
you know, got together,
and managed to have the country
to reverse the opening up
that we had in 1990.
So, one last song of this
period, you know, don't do
don't try to open up
and revive your currency
at the same time, you know.
Fortunately now we have a
floating exchange rate, you know.
So, what you would expect
in the case of opening up,
you know, if that, you know
as the financial sector
anticipates a flood of imports,
and that in the consequences,
you know, demand for dollars
if the financial sector itself
would anticipate this demand
for dollars and would devalue
the currency, you know.
So that could be, you
know, a natural consequence
of the work is off a
floating exchange rate.
But anyways, you know,
currently this is not an issue,
you know, because for reasons that I think
the international press
are propagating quite well.
You know the disgrace, that
this government is, you know,
we have the over devalued
currency today, you know,
in Brazil.
Three years ago, you know,
the real was worth,
we need three reals for the dollar,
you know, and now we need the
five and a half times reals
for the dollar.
So, Brazil has a very subsist
is it possible now, you know,
to allege that the exchange
rate is not competitive
is extremely competitive
and this should provide
a very good occasion to opening up.
- That's it that's right.
I wanna go on vacation as soon as COVID,
it gives us a reprieve.
Yeah, so it is true just
a short comment on what
you've just the point you've just made
that naturally opening up
to trade that coming in
from imports tends to
put pressure downloads,
and the exchange rates to devalue.
But the other hand, hopefully
it fosters investment
which tends to push it up a little bit.
But, you know, at the moment,
it doesn't seem to be an issue at all.
Let me, I think we're 10 minutes away.
And I see there are quite
a few questions in the Q&A.
So, I'd like to turn to the audience.
So, I guess I can.
- Yes, sorry
- So, Scott, I don't know
if you have selected.
- I'm just trying to
stop that screen share.
We do have quite a few
questions coming in.
Thank you both for the
really engaging lecture,
and discussion so far.
Our first question comes from actually one
of our current IDE
students, Beatriz Nunez.
Professor Bacha, we have a more
specific question regarding
the URV.
Why did the real plan
use one virtual currency,
and one physical currency instead
of two physical currencies?
- Well, the original blend, you know,
that it's called the Laritha lamb
as Rudy Dornbusch named it.
It was presented in 1985 in Washington
had this idea of you know,
letting two currency circulates,
simultaneous, you know.
One it is the old currency
that is depreciating
the other that was, you know,
index to the dollar.
And then people shift
from the old currency
to the new currency.
And once this process was
sufficiently advanced, you know,
inflation would have disappeared.
The problem is that that to
have a simultaneous circulation
of two currencies, you
know, it's very complicated,
you know.
It's not even clear that this
constitutional, you know.
So we, we decide that it
too complicated, too much
you know, people.
We had a very bad experience
in Czechoslovakia in 1944
when they had these two
currency system that they had
the highest hyperinflation in
the world up until Zimbabwe
came up on the way recently.
So, we decide to you know,
rather than have we have
a pre currency together with
the old currency, you know,
is the pre currency
the unit of real value?
Whose value was $1.
And then we allowed, you
know, first we decreed
a force change of wages
include the new currency accord
the in order to maintain
the same parity that
the wage had over time,
under high inflation.
And now also we converted
some other things like rents,
and school fees, according
to according to the law.
But then we allow for a four month period
for everyone else, you know,
to change their contracts
into URVs, you know.
And after we are satisfied to, you know,
there are sufficiently people
converting into our URVs.
Actually one of our colleagues
who said that he believed
that the plan was a success
that once he was going
to the beach to the Panama
Beach, and he looked
at a stand, you know,
and saw that the price
of one coco was $1.
So, if you want coconut, you
know, was $1 sorry, not $1,
one URV.
So that if I'm the guy who's
selling coconuts in the beach
you don't understand what URV was,
we were ready to do the shift, you know.
And that's why we made this, you know,
and in this process, you know,
we were very successful.
Actually in all the
public broadcasting system
has the a broadcast a database
is available on YouTube
if you want to read, you know.
They had a very bad title,
you know, I complained to them
but they did not change the name's "How
four drinking buddies,
managed to stop the inflation
the country," you know?
So anyways, so that's basically
the reason you don't do it.
They do currency system is very
complicated to do, you know.
So we did it half of the suggestion.
And I think that was very good.
- I mean, personally I
think that's a great title
for an article.
So, I would be honored if I were you.
We have another great question from one
of our participants, Ravisha Gupta.
With COVID related disruptions
in global supply chains
now may be a good time
for countries in Latin
America and Sub-Saharan Africa
to enter these chains and
open up to more trade.
What would be some
requisite domestic features
at the country level for this to happen?
And are there any countries
doing this right now?
- Well, right now, you know,
that's is big discussion here though
that the people protectionists,
you know, are saying
"See this guy who wants
to open up, you know.
If you are dependent on foreigners
when we need them, most, you know,
is where they don't have the
things available, you know.
Like difficulties or
getting vaccines in Brazil.
It's not even getting the
vaccines to get the inputs
to the vaccines, you know.
So, there's this tremendous
protectionism in the US.
Now, you know, that has so many vaccines
you know, it's not using AstraZeneca.
I know there's 30 million sitting down.
I don't know where, you
know, why don't you give it
to other countries,
you know, that are very
very happy Brazil to use
the AstraZenecas that
are sitting up in the US you
know, without being used,
and also probably becoming,
become useless, you know,
because of the date of aggravation.
So you the question,
but otherwise, you know,
what people really see, you know,
from those who are not extreme
protectionists, you know.
It's how important is
international collaboration,
you know, how important are
these integration in order
to produce you know,
this successful vaccines
that we have now, you know.
They, the Pfizer, no it's half Germans
is half Americans it's as
a substantial component
of Chinese, you know.
And so this is true, you know,
people, I think that are in
in the labs, the pharmaceutical
industry here in Brazil,
they are very quite clear, you know,
they cannot do it alone.
You know, they don't want
protection, you know.
They want to have ways of
integrating and support of
the government for innovation, you know,
like the warped speed process did.
You know, Brazil cannot afford
a work suite, obviously.
But obviously this is the
way supporting innovation.
That the way to go ahead.
- Professor Feiler, do you
have any thing to add on this?
- No, I fully agree with Professor Bacha,
that with the world especially
from the perspective
of developing countries
are actually gaining
from the development of
new vaccines coming in from
the US, yeah US, England
and other countries said
that themselves are not vaccines coming
from insular countries, but
are coming in from scientists
from all over the world in
parts from all over the world.
So, yes, I don't really
have much to add there.
- Right, thank you.
Well, so we only have time
for a couple of more questions,
maybe one or two more.
I'm just gonna ask.
We have a one just came
in from Eduardo Costa,
Professor Bacha, in your view
what's the possible or
potential contribution
that the Brazilian Amazon region can make
to the economic growth
and development of Brazil.
There's a Brazilian
scientist, Doctor Nobre,
who refers to Amazon 4.0 as
possible new wave of innovation,
and productivity based on sustainable use
of biodiversity resources in the Amazon
to produce marketable products.
How do you see Amazon
making a contribution
in the world in the near future?
- Well, first of all,
you'll have to put pressure
on the current government not
to stop destroying the Amazon.
And hopefully this is the
first line of defense.
You know, if we're going to
have the Amazon, you know.
We have to make sure that
the destructive policies
of this government stopped in its tracks.
You know, we very successful,
you know, in one aspect
which is getting rid of the foreign
the foreign minister here,
was a crazy man, you know
but also the current, the minister of the
the minister of that
deals with the Amazon.
Now, let's also you end gash on his, Oh
he does not believe in
this in global warming.
He wants and Bolsonaro is
overly a stupid person.
He wants to develop the Amazon,
or he could destroy it or,
you know, in order to have for development
the way that we did in 19,
US did in the 19th century,
did it, you know for
most of the 20th century,
he would go ahead.
Then also we have to stop
these guy first, you know.
And to alert the pressure of
the international community
is very important.
Second, you know, there's
this whole question.
Or if you have a reasonable government,
suppose we can find
Biden, our Biden, you know
in 2022, one year and a half from now,
what should we do about the Amazon?
well, first of all, you know
we have to find a way to get rid of
the Zona Franca de Manaus you know,
which is a place in Manaus,
which produces industrial
goods, very expensive.
And it's a thing that's
only serves, you know,
that import the components,
you fabricate the product,
you know, the bike bicycle, for example,
and then you shift it Sao Paulo.
You know, it's just a way
of make it more expensive
industrial products
that we could have more easily
without this intermediation.
But then you have to put
something you stand there, right?
And people in the Amazon
say, "Well, there's, if
if people don't fabricate
this goods, you know,
they're going to destroy the forest."
So we have to find an
alternative employment
for these people, you know.
There are lots of people
in Amazon, you know,
it's 20 million people.
I don't know if the Amazon
can carry 20 million people,
you know, perhaps we should
in the process, you know,
think of ways because
biotechnology, you know,
people are very set, "Oh,
the forest is fully off
this new products that
you know, that they could use."
And yes, I think there
are some bare, you know.
But not sufficient to make 20 people,
20 million people sufficiently productive,
sufficiently have an
income sufficiently high.
So, we have to find, you
know, a combination, you know,
of preservation.
But in order to preserve we
have to pay off, you know,
these people who are there
and who would not find
the productive employment in
the way that is consistent
with the preservation of the forest.
- Rohini, I'm just checking in to see
if you had anything to add
here before we wrap up.
I see that we're getting to time.
- No, I think this was a
fascinating discussion.
I learned a lot.
So, thank you to both Professor
Bacha and Professor Fieler,
and we we'll be able to
meet on campus in the fall
or sometime soon
- We also too, thank
you for organizing this.
- Okay, in the campus and
at Sally's and Pepe's.
- Yeah, exactly.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.